20 million people saw 'i'm nearing a
world record-breaking freediver jump
into the abyss at dean's blue hole in
the bahamas 20 million views is a lot a
lot of people love this video yes this
video seems to show qiyam dives 660 feet
to the bottom and return to the surface
on just one breath this is amazing
I want to get to know this guy agreed we
travel to Nice France to meet him and
his wife Julie Gautier now not them
this is Geum and here's Julie who filmed
the incredible video freediving is the
art of going in the water on the single
breath so the idea is to redefine the
limits and trying to dive as deep as
possible Oh Mike's this video so special
is that he's not wearing any scuba gear
he's just diving into the water he's
leaping into the unknown and he's just
enjoying it for the moment you are one
with the water you are one with the
elements and this is something very
great this is really remarkable
it's a superhuman feat a superhuman feat
that is definitely fiction not bad is it
a fake hidden is the real the idea was
not to pretend I touched the bottom the
idea was to make a beautiful film an
artistic film that was different than
what we are used to see underwater so
why can't qiyam free dive that far
the main problem we're trying to do a
dive like this is that you would run out
of oxygen so the top of the diving takes
a breath but then as soon as he hits the
water and dives deeper and deeper
there's more and more pressure on his
body now for most of your body that
doesn't make a lot of difference because
they're reasonably not compressible but
your lungs which are full of gas are
quite compressible and if they get
squeezed by the water pressure that
means is less surface area inside them
and so it's much more difficult for your
body to extract the oxygen from that
you also see them moving around a lot
and that's something that free divers
tend not to do because the more you move
the more you work the more your body
uses up oxygen in real life the actual
record for an unaided free dive is about
101 meters or 331 feet now that's a very
long way but it's only about half as far
as going on claims to have gone in this
dive so this video is fake and here's
how they did it he really did free dive
through the entrance of dean's blue hole
which is only about nine meters or
thirty feet down and he continued diving
a little while while they filmed him but
all the footage you see of him walking
around on the bottom is not really the
bottom it's just a rocky outcropping
somewhere near the top we did this dis
film for the free diving community we
didn't expect it was about to go viral
for us it was so obvious that nobody
would believe that because when we know
it's impossible I had to write to some
newspaper to say no no please don't say
I touch the bottom I didn't touch the
bottom and they said it doesn't matter
beautiful yes it certainly is
breathtaking